aber für alle die cat ballou jetzt nicht
kennen für die haben einen kleinen film
vorbereitet das war nina niebergall
sie besingen ein lebensgefühl kölner
frohsinn gemeinschaft liebe zur stadt
und natürlich zum karneval
cat ballou spätestens 2012 mit ihrem
mega-hit mitten im karnevalstreiben
angekommen normalerweise stehen sie ab
dem 11.11 wochenlang auf der bühne
[Musik]
mit immer neuen songs
ok
sie tun es immer wieder und mit ihnen
hunderttausende karnevalisten nur dieses
jahr tun sie es nicht
corona hat auch den karneval weitgehend
lahmgelegt karnevals konzerte finden
zwar pandemie gerechtem autokino stadt
die kölner werden kreativ um wenigstens
ein bisschen feiern zu können
und doch fehlt vielen arbeit musik bands
tanzgruppen in der bühnentechnik der
beleuchtung hinter den kulissen für sie
wurde die initiative nicht allein ins
leben gerufen dabei rausgekommen spenden
in höhe von knapp einer million euro und
ein neuer song
[Musik]
die botschaft du bist nicht allein
und bald feiern wir wieder zusammen
karneval so wie früher
das hoffen wir zumindest so oliver kahn
es mich jetzt besser hören richtig auch
ich höre ich genauso schlecht und
doppelt wie vorher aber ich glaube ich
komme damit zurecht
das ist ein traum heute hier wieder aber
wir mögen uns da jetzt irgendwie durch
lieber oliver tanzen wir da mal sagen
wie wichtig ist ein karneval für euch
jetzt als band oder auch ganz einfach
zum brot verdienen also auf jeden fall
ist das unsere haupteinnahmequelle das
kann man schon sagen wir spielen zwar
das ganze jahr über und geht auch
deutschland touren
aber nicht so gewalt das haben wir 200
auftritte das heißt wenn ihr jetzt diese
saison quasi ausfällt wie weh tut euch
das ja das ist schon schwierig wir sind
schon am haken so aber was machen wenn
man muss das halt in den blick ich habe
auch gesehen es gab konzerte im autokino
die habt ihr auch gespielt genau wir
haben jetzt in den letzten tagen
20.27 auch kritiker aber es ist eine
ganz andere sache aber das war schon
cool wir haben auch spaß aber wie können
wir das vorstellen also sondern so eine
rockband die vom die vor 150 autos ab
geht das musste auch so ein bisschen
merkwürdig sein vom feeling her oder
ja es auf jeden fall also die ersten
auftritte waren seltsam
das muss man schon sagen aber wenn man
dann gemerkt hat dass leute auf ja wenn
die wenn man die stimmung oben
irgendwann kann die stimmung gehoben und
dann verkauft hat das hat sich
eigentlich immer weiter hochgeschaukelt
dass wir am ende eigentlich jetzt dann
doch auch traurig
das heißt ihr verhalten dass bei mit dem
autokino so nächstes jahr also wir
natürlich nicht wenn es die einzige
möglichkeit ist dann nehmen wir sind das
neue umfeld ihr habt ja sicher viele
bekannte die künstler sind die mit oder
auf der bühne arbeiten
wie geht es den gerade und was machen
die jetzt eigentlich wenn einer mal
ausfällt also uns direkt im umfeld also
unsere unsere technik versagt weil die
für immer fest dabei haben die haben wir
auch das ganze jahr über mit dabei da
ist natürlich eine menge arbeit gerade
weggefallen
jetzt der staat 230 jobs und das ist
natürlich eine menge aber zum beispiel
unser haupt zu und man der ist eine
festanstellung gegangen muss dadurch
jetzt natürlich ein bisschen jonglieren
und so das ist natürlich das ging die
versuchen jetzt anderweitig halt jobs zu
kriegen
und damit gehen sie uns ein bisschen
flöten und das ist glaube ich auch so
ein bisschen das grundproblem aber es
gibt natürlich auch aus dem direkten
umfeld hört man da auch ganz andere
beispiele so und wo hat nicht mal eben
so dass ganze kompensiert werden kann
und das ist natürlich dann sehr schlimm
das heißt leute die tatsächlich in die
grundsicherung rutschen oder wie müssen
wir uns vorstellen
ja absolut also letztendlich haben wir
das ganze ja auch von unserer
altersvorsorge gelebt halt ne das muss
man jetzt muss man sich auch sorgen um
mich machen dass sie irgendwann mit 85
noch auf der bühne steht in köln dann
weil ihr euch nix an sparen konnte
ich sage mal so wir erhoffen uns das
einfach mal dass wir mit 85 auf der
bühne stehen aber das sind sehr ein
anderer hintergrund okay ist auch ein
live geholt das war natürlich leute hier
im stream die sind keine karnevalsfans
vielleicht kannst du mal erklären für
die warum für euch das so wichtig ist
warum das auch für köln so wichtig ist
also gerne weil ist also von außen
betrachtet hat man bestimmt schnell das
gefühl dass es einfach nur ein lautes
feiern wo viel gesoffen wird und so aber
es ist viel viel mehr also das ist fängt
ja schon für ein kleines kind ja schon
an was irgendwie zum zugeht und so ich
weiß ja selber von mir und wir wachsen
hier damit auf und da entsteht einfach
ein lebensgefühl und das nimmt man mit
in die jugend- und dann hat man auch mal
phasen wo man das ganze nicht so cool
findet und so und dann kommt man aber
wieder dazu zurück und es hat auch der
karneval ist so vielschichtig dass das
da kann ich den ganzen abend mit dir
darüber philosophieren und
es ist halt wie gesagt mehr als laut
sein und alkohol trinken es ist sehr
viel gefühl kann da auch bei sein und
sehr viel herz das heißt heute ist für
dich auch ihren tag zum trauern oder
versuchst du das einfach weg zu drücken
ja also ich habe auf jeden fall so wir
fangen immer so ab dem 56 an zu spielen
und dann bis aschermittwoch und in der
ganzen zeit die jetzt also ist ja schon
ein paar wochen hatte ich schon so ein
paar phasen wo es mir nicht so gut ging
und war wirklich sehr traurig aber dass
das betraf das ganze ja eigentlich also
wir hatten der deutschlandtour vor der
nase hatten unplugged uhr das alles
ausgefallen und hatten stattdessen bei
auto kino konzerte was schön war aber
wenn man das dass ich manchmal bewusst
macht was bei gerade alles so flöten
geht nicht nur für uns finanziell
sondern hat auch wirklich an gefühl wir
machen das ja auch aus einer
leidenschaft also auf der bühne stehen
und mit den leuten dann gemeinsam feiern
und auch für ich gehe auch selber gerne
auf konzerte also das ist ein endloses
rat so das ist schon sehr traurig es
gibt ja auch babbel im stream die
software schon komisch heute ohne alles
als kölnerin also da fehlt dann in der
stadt ja schon was auch schön auch einen
kommentar an dich ist es schön zu sehen
wie du strahlst wenn du vom karneval
erzählt das kann man tatsächlich aber
nur nachvollziehen wenn man das wenn man
damit aufgewachsen ist vermutlich oder
ganze auch leute die da reingewachsen
sind gerne auf jeden fall auch eine
menge leute die das normale sporadisch
erlebt haben und dann es kommt halt
darauf an wo man ist in dem moment also
man kann glaube ich sehr viele bilder
vom karneval erwischen und die sehen wir
auch als bierkenner wirklich alle
facetten weil wir wenn wir 200 auftritte
spielen spielen wir auf so
unterschiedlichen veranstaltungen und da
gibt es auch nicht so schöne bilder also
aber in meinem kopf bleibt er das
positive und ja es ist wie alle mit
allem im leben es gibt immer zwei seiten
und das ganze ist ja wenn man schon
gesagt doch eine sache wo auch viele
jobs dran hängen also wo viele leute
auch tatsächlich jahreseinkommen
rausholen hast du auch gerade gesagt
eure haupteinnahmequelle
hast du das gefühl dass von der
unterstützung der politik da jetzt genug
unterstützung ankommt max oder was von
also klar erhalten wir unterstützung es
natürlich nicht das was wir sonst haben
und das ja ich bin da also auf jeden
fall weit davon entfernt irgendwie über
irgendwas zu schimpfen oder irgendwie zu
urteilen oder so da
da bin ich der falsche für aber das
große problem ist halt das ja die die
ungewissheit in der zukunft wir wissen
nicht wie können wir planen und dass uns
die techniker halt flöten gehen die
basis sind ja auch unsere techniker also
ohne die können wir nicht auftreten und
wenn die irgendwann auch in anderen jobs
hängen dann dann geht halt also es geht
gerade sehr viel kaputt was wir uns
immer sehr viele jahre an gearbeitet
haben und bei bands oder auch anderen
auch tanzgruppen oder ganz vielen
anderen personen die sich da etwas
aufgebaut haben in der letzten zeit der
bericht als eine menge weg und dadurch
geht sehr viel kultur flöten und da muss
man halt ja was machen
ihr habt ja schon was gemacht ihr habt
versucht zusammen mit anderen geld zu
sammeln haben wir gerade gesehen im
einspieler eine million euro sind fasst
zusammen gekommen ich würde jetzt mal so
aus dem gefühl heraus behaupten richtig
reichen tut das wahrscheinlich aber
nicht oder nee das ist natürlich runter
gebrochen jetzt nicht so viel wenn man
überlegt wie viele leute dann im
karneval aktiv sind und wie viele da
gerade am krebsen sind aber es ist halt
für uns war es von vornherein hat ganz
klar ein solidarisches zeichen so muss
man es halt machen dass man halt
aufeinander acht gibt und das war halt
auch unsere unser beweggrund bei dem
ersten video was man zu der single du
bist nicht allein gemacht haben haben
halt einfach gedacht das lied ist so ein
hoffnungsvolles lied und wenn wir diesem
video machen dann lenken wir das
augenmerk ganz glaubt die gastro und auf
die kleinen klubs die hat gerade echt
krass leiden und haben halten video
draus gemacht noch mal die leeren clubs
ab gezeigt und
viele leute aus der gastro wie sie halt
gerade links zu tun haben und wir
wollten halt einfach ein bisschen
augenmerk darauf lenken und dass wir
echte aufeinander ein bisschen acht
geben
es ist die große frage was kann jeder
einzelne eigentlich von uns tunis gab es
am anfang also im ersten block sein
letztes jahr so diese initiative dass
man gutscheine gekauft ein bisschen das
gefühl dass es so ausgelaufen hast du
irgendeine idee was jeder einzelne tun
kann wenn er oder sie jetzt weiß okay da
gibt es eine band da gibt es eine kneipe
die liegt mir am herzen
also da kenne ich weiß ich jetzt nicht
so genau bescheid direkt aber ich oder
wir haben immer für uns gesagt dass wenn
irgendwo sicherheitskonzepte bestehen
und es gibt die möglichkeit also sei es
autokino konzerte wir hatten im sommer
auch bestuhlte konzerte auf so
liegestühlen und sowas
das sind ja konzepte die extra dafür
gemacht wurden das ist absolut sicher
ist unter unter freiem himmel und
draußen und und in dem moment wo halt
wieder sachen möglich sind sollte man
die auch einfach unbedingt wahrnehmen
und wir haben jetzt eine sehr sehr
positive erfahrung mit den autokino
konzerten gemacht und ich glaube auch
die leute die im publikum waren ich
selber bin eigentlich einer der sehr
gerne auf konzerte geht ja wo ist dann
halt auch wo man einen kleinen klub
zusammensteht und schwitzt und tanzt und
so aber ich habe am ende auch gesagt ich
könnte mir vorstellen auch so ein
autokino konzert zu fahren weil
irgendwie wäre das halt gerade die
einzige möglichkeit und wenn irgendwie
meine lieblingsband kommt dann will ich
dir sehen und dann würde ich das auch
machen und deshalb glaube ich alles das
was ein kultur geht sollte man annehmen
und dann dadurch schätzt man es dann
auch wert ich frage mich aber gerade bei
solchen kleinen clubkonzerten manchmal
so ein bisschen können wir das überhaupt
noch nächstes jahr anderen wir jetzt
irgendwie anderthalb jahre oder ein jahr
darauf verzichtet haben immer wenn ich
jetzt bilder siehe auch jetzt gerade vom
kam aber letztes jahr oder vorletzte ist
ja denke ich immer oh gott hier steht
viel zu nah beieinander
ihr habt euch an geht da weg meinst du
wir können das wieder verlernen
ja klar also ich hoffe es also das ist
natürlich was wir kennen das ihr alle
selbst hab letztens die simpsons geguckt
und dachte mir oh ihr seid euch zu nahe
gekommen das sind kartuschen
und das ist natürlich schon sehr tief
verwurzelt aber ja keine ahnung haben
ich habe letztens noch mal videos
gesehen eine rose 1000 menschen waren
genauso häufig aber auch wir sehen oder
videos einem clubkonzert in münchen
da waren 600 leute in dem antrag
backstage club ist auch für 600 leute
genau ausgelegt war pickepackevoll und
das sind schon bilder diese die wirken
wie vor von vor fünf jahre und irgendwie
das ist schon weit weg aber ich hoffe
einfach dass es so schnell wie möglich
wieder kommt und dass es dann auch so
das ist dann auch wieder hemmungslos ist
dass man eben nicht das gefühl hat wir
sind zu nahe und du hast mich doch
gerade angespuckt
das passiert ja auch schlimm wenn man so
nah ist dann hoffen wir dass tatsächlich
so bleibt wollen wir vielen dank toller
abend zeit für uns hatte ist aber seien
wir ehrlich so viel anderes gibt es sei
gerade wahrscheinlich auch nichts zu tun
außer vielleicht einen tipp hier von
double aus köln der sich trotzdem
verkleidet und hat in einem call mit
anderen zusammen karneval säcken
gefeiert also irgendwie wenn man möchte
geht es dann doch auch weil er danke dir
nach köln klar
man sollte alles machen ja vielen dank
auch etwas gutes
und damit kommen wir zu unserem nächsten
gesprächsgast nämlich zu zanetti ist
seit zehn jahren ein fester bestandteil
der deutschen comedy-szene die lebt auch
vor allem von live auftritten und corona
hat das ganze ziemlich an die wand
gefahren genau wie den rest der
unterhaltungsbranche und ich schaue
jetzt einfach mal ob die leitung zur
tanne steht kannst du nicht hören hey
ich kann nicht hören das sieht doch gut
aus du bist comedian das heißt die erste
frage hatten sich tatsächlich muss muss
tatsächlich sein was was ist dein
lieblings corona wird so war oder davon
dem balkon auch noch keine wird zu
machen ich gerade mal ein jahr in der
pandemie drin ich glaube wir müssen wir
zu machen auf jeden fall so zeit wäre
das alles nicht mehr aus humor ist ja
ein mittel zum verarbeiten von dingen
die uns angst machen die uns verwundern
ersten und so weiter und die uns seltsam
vorkommen deswegen muss man das
irgendwie verarbeiten und mit humor geht
das total gut und es geht ja vor allen
dingen um unser eigenes verhalten und um
das verhalten unserer mitmenschen was
manchmal sehr seltsam ist während
soziale noch an den ersten locker und wo
alle angefangen habe diesen krassen
hamsterkäufen von klopapier und da hat
es ja nur so von - gehagelt und das geht
ja überhaupt witze und so weiter also es
gibt nichts was ich jetzt als lieblings
corona witz habe ich habe letztens was
gelesen irgendwie wie beschimpfte sich
coronaviren mit impf wärtern das ist
natürlich ein sehr radek verstehen sie
aber den vielleicht ganz lustig oder
irgendwie so ich habe das am sonntag
steht mittlerweile dass sich übrigens
ganz schlimm diese dosen lacher dann
lieber weise jeder lacht irgendwie
gerade so für sich alleine zu hause das
ist auch vollkommen okay ich finde diese
eingespielte nach haben war sehr seltsam
tatsächlich aber man wird ja mit mit
allen möglichen bildmaterial und
videomaterial irgendwie über kronawitter
dazu zugeballert gibt es ein koma wird
es nicht machen würdest es ist immer so
eine gefühlssache also das ist ja echt
immer so ein eigener bereich wo man
merkt ich glaube hier ist jetzt so meine
grenze und ich habe vielleicht eine
andere grenze als jemand anderes also
jemand fühlt sich vielleicht auf den
schlips getreten oder jetzt vielleicht
dann doch nicht also es ist immer so ein
sohn rantasten aber es gibt glaube ich
so grundwerte die man nicht verlässt und
darauf kann man sich immer einigen ja so
jetzt komme ich gucke einfach in die
kommentare hier haben wir auf jeden fall
karnevalsfans dabei die sagen die welt
ist esel ernst gemeint dass werden auf
facebook da braucht man die
faschingszeit dafür haben wir nächstes
jahr doppelt rhein kann mir nur wünschen
und es gibt auch heute tatsächlich sehe
ich hier der michael marx auf facebook
der feiert mit freunden bude es
geschmückt und alles läuft die über die
balkone stelle ich mir gerade sehr kalt
vor aber solange das safe ist ja alles
gut
das schöne daran mir geht er war echt
zählen auch die woche in weinflaschen
ich bin ich aber in welcher weinflasche
woche sind wir eigentlich gerade ich
habe es ein bisschen das zeitgefühl
verloren ehrlich gesagt mach ich ihn
kenne die zahlen unterschiedlich das
wird gefährlich ok bevor bei dir noch
leute vorbeikommen und weinflaschen
einsammeln wollen du kommst aus
heinsberg das ist natürlich jetzt
gezwungenermaßen auch lustig und hast du
natürlich auch gleich mit einem programm
eingebaut dass wir dankenswerterweise
bei unserem schwester sender 3sat
ausstrahlen durften ein teil davon und
da gucken uns jetzt in kurzen ausschnitt
von an 1 wird muss ich gott sei dank
seit ein paar monaten nicht mehr
erklären
sonst muss ich jetzt immer ganz
umgestellt ich erkläre ein kleines dorf
an der holländischen grenze und jetzt
ist so falle die sonst so nicht wissen
heinsberg hat das größte fledermaus
reservat deutschlands das ist also der
heizwerk war natürlich der erste riesige
cola- skandale oder das ist natürlich
geil wenn das der ort ist mit dem du
jetzt verbunden bis das großartig da
mussten sich zwei idioten wieder denken
das war übrigens auch bei karneval wie
ganzen sache an sich gedacht haben würde
ja ich habe kostüme gekauft bei 30 euro
kostet wir jetzt nutzen
und dann sagt einer leute infizierten
also eher sind ja das war schön letztes
jahr kurze investigative frage stimmt
den fledermaus reservat ja das war
natürlich der gag weil der korona virus
darüber quasi auf den menschen
übergesprungen dass sie das war so
helfen das versuchen und das war genau
ich sollte etwas mit unterhaltung machen
das passiert mir hier durch lieder aber
genauso ist es nun entweder lacht man
oder man lacht nicht aber tatsächlich
aber gerade in kurz zugehört und da war
es auch so wir haben das aufgezeichnet
auch unter corona bedingungen bei 3sat
und das war auch in einer riesigen halle
wo natürlich super weit auseinander
gezogene tisch mit ein paar leuten saßen
und so richtig stimmung will dann
einfach nicht aufkommen und das ist
natürlich für humor auch essenziell dass
ein vollgepackter raum da ist und leute
und das vermisse ich total also publikum
und diesen moment erleben die energie
und so und dafür lebe ich schnell für
die bühne und das ist natürlich jetzt
gerade einfach weg leider geht das denn
trotzdem also ist es oder wird zu sagen
das ist eigentlich ein ding der
unmöglichkeit und bevor wenig wieder eng
gepackt irgendwo zusammenstehen können
kann ich nicht mehr auftreten
na also es geht natürlich schon aber es
ist transportiert nicht dasselbe gefühl
wie vorher
deswegen freue ich mich umso mehr auf
diesen moment wenn es denn wieder geht
und oliver zwar gerade auch schon gesagt
diese autokino sache ich habe am anfang
mich total dagegen gewehrt zum beispiel
auch gesagt nee ich mach das nicht das
fühlt sich selbst aber ich kann da nicht
für autos comedy machen und an ein paar
kollegen die das gemacht haben gesagt
probierst du wenigstens einmal das ist
wirklich eine coole sache
und dann habe ich es gemacht und das war
wirklich toll also im ersten moment ist
natürlich seltsam weil du stehst da wie
so ein überambitionierte autoverkäufer
vor der sonne braten will als wird zum
morgenkaffee rausgehen sein da ist alles
meins es war echt cool während die leute
sollten ja eigentlich nur lichthupe
machen aber wir haben es echt sehr
ausgereizt ist zweimal sogar das
ordnungsamt aber die wollten die
veranstaltung dann unterbringen aber wir
haben es das war dann gegen ende
deswegen war es okay und das hat echt
spaß gemacht also die leute waren so
laut die haben teilweise sich über ziele
auf die scheibenwischer gebastelt um
also mit so handschuhe damit sie winken
und plakate
bastelt und leute hatten pizza dabei und
einer hat sogar eine shisha im auto
gehabt
es war echt jetzt hat es ein bisschen
festivalcharakter das war wirklich schön
also ich glaube auch sollte das nächstes
jahr irgendwie immer noch der status quo
sein dass wir nicht normal spielen würde
ich das auf jeden fall noch mal machen
einfach damit wir irgendwie ein
kulturerlebnis haben und es quasi den
bettel für comedians bei wem kommt das
ordnungsamt öfter wegen des google ja
sehr schön mit ihm mit live schalte ich
habe mir das programm von michael
mittermeier angeguckt hat auch bei 3sat
gespielt und der hat erzählt dass er
seinem umfeld weil er kein publikum
hatte tierisch auf die nerven gegangen
ist weil er die ganze zeit witze bewusst
werden muss er einen witz stau gehabt
hat er gesagt das ist bei dir auch so
gewesen
ja also hin und wieder ich habe ja auch
sehr stille momente ich bin ja nicht
immer komplett im comedy modus ich habe
er so stimmen torrent parodiert auch
sehr viel und da muss man eine freundin
zu hause mal sehr viel aushalten weil
sie dann nicht weiß mit wem die familie
und das ist dann manchmal sehr
anstrengend ich bin dann auch selber von
mir genervt manchmal war ich weiß wohin
damit weil das ist natürlich sonst auf
der bühne perfekte energie ausgleich na
das ist ja wie so ein work ordner
welcher zwei stunden stehe und total
alles rauslassen kann und die leute
mitnehmen kann und dann falle ich
nachher auch tot ins bett irgendwie und
das ist natürlich jetzt nicht der fall
deswegen ist es ein bisschen lauter zu
hause das stück schon beeindruckend
finde ich einmal relativ ist meine tiefe
männliche stimme also da habe ich mich
gefragt wie geht das denn meinte die
katy karrenbauer nummer dieses
ein externes mikro meinte dass wir die
ich habe total zu hause will ich auch
allen auf den wecker gegangen damit
früher als ich aufgewachsen bin in
heinsberg einem meine eltern diesen
durchgedreht und mir also ich bin nach
der schule absolut tasche in die ecke
geschmissen habe den ganzen tag nur
geräusche gemacht mein bruder hat nur
geschrieben deswegen über bühne
eigentlich hatte ich keine andere option
als diesen job zu reden ja manchmal muss
man auch sehr aus dem elend machen die
kann er erst aus deiner sicht die
unterhaltungsbranche überleben also hast
du da hast du da irgendwelche ideen über
konzepte ja es ist natürlich total
schwierig weil also die ganzen künstler
innen sind natürlich nur so die spitze
des eisbergs oliver hat ja eben auch
schon gesagt dass dieser ganze unterbau
den es braucht von bühnentechniker
bühnen bauern caterer veranstalter
theater
das ist ein riesen wirtschaftssektor
denn natürlich total bedroht ist und das
zieht sich natürlich jetzt und die
hilfen die sind noch nicht wirklich da
wo sie sollen und ich bin jetzt mal
gespannt wie es mit der
überbrückungshilfe 3 geht das auch
irgendwie solo selbstständige ein
bisschen besser über die runden kommen
also wie gesagt gutscheine kaufen ist
super und jedes wenn es denn bei einem
selber geht weil wir sind ja alle gerade
irgendwie und wissen deine weiß nicht
mehr wo es wo man was man machen soll
und so dass es geht ja nicht nur
künstler künstler und künstlerinnen so
sondern in den unterschiedlichsten
sektoren deswegen wenn es denn geht
gutscheine kaufen und sich auf jedes
kultur erlebnis freuen und ja das ist
dann bald wieder geht ansonsten wenn man
sich informieren will die initiative
alarmstufe rot gibt es und da gibt es
auch die ganzen demos veranstaltungen
für den ganzen veranstaltung sektor und
das ist eine gute sache und zur not
daneben auch ins autokino fahren um dann
da mal wieder kultur zu erleben
genau autokino und wer weiß vielleicht
was was die pandemie noch so bringen
vielleicht finden die bundeskanzlerin
abgedankt hatte
kommen sie auch noch mit einem kombi
soloprogramm um die ecke ist muss eine
reise durch deutschland das war doch
auch ganz cool
das wäre auf jeden fall cool ich hab mit
kleinen zweifel auch nicht du den job
übernehmen muss aber da bist du eh bald
dran ich glaube da läuft dann ja auch
eine entsprechende kleine comedyserie
bald in einem benachbarten streaming
anbieter den wir jetzt nicht mehr nennen
wollen seine vielen dank dass du heute
abend zeit wird uns hatte
und wir wünschen natürlich schöne
auftritte auch wenn nur vor drei leuten
oder 30 autos vielen dank bleibt alle
gesund dankeschön so und ich sag' ich
euch auch danke an diesem rosenmontag
der sich nicht die anfühlt wie ein
rosenmontag aber es ist tatsächlich
einer gewesen am aschermittwoch ist dann
auch dass wieder alles vorbei und wir
können nur aufs nächste jahr hoffen dass
es dann doch vielleicht besser wird
zumindest die menschen die kann aber
mögen ich habe den film gesehen ein paar
mögen es auch nicht das ist natürlich
absolut legitim der rest freut sich
jetzt die können sich jetzt freuen dass
dieses jahr aufgefallen ist der rest
versucht so gut wie möglich zu
verarbeiten und jetzt wünsch euch noch
einen schönen abend und sagt es zum
nächsten mal
macht's gut und tschüss